political analyst for Sinclair Broadcast
Group and former special assistance
President Trump at the White House Boris
Epstein thanks for coming by yeah well
no I'm the one who has to thank you this
is not an easy week for you and not an
easy audience to come and speak in front
of so I know that takes some balls and I
appreciate that it really does and you
have a big new job you are Sinclair I
don't know people know this this is
another big story that kind of got
buried
Sinclair group they're a television
conglomerate they were trying to buy
tribute and they look like going to get
it you're going to be one of the main
people there that they want to be to the
right of Fox News now that's not quite
true
that's so true that's not so really
think oh there is not a cable channel I
know here's a group that owned stations
and it's a provider of content and it
provides content that's straight down
the middle
straight but that's what Fox used to say
fair and balanced and we know they're
but Fox a cable channel right so it's
different it's not different was it look
difference it did whether it comes
over-the-air an accord if they hire
viewers their front man they're not
going down not about the front man so
I'm the chief political analyst I'm an
analyst and what I'll be doing is
providing segments go play on their
station they go to the station up get
o'clock local news you'll see that is
straight down the Auris this was
supposed to be the I'm nice to you
question I like it but by that's I'm
sure the warmth I'm feeling than what's
right here I think it's great let's try
to
I love it I was trying to congratulate
on your new job I think yes all right so
let's get to this and look I don't want
to make this adversarial obviously we
are from different sides of the spectrum
but look as long as you keep it straight
with me that's not what okay it doesn't
have to go out of the box but I you know
first off how long do you think Donald
Trump can be president as we president
for eight years
yeah people thought he would never be
prepped all right well but even after
the events of this week absolutely okay
chica what how about we have a
gentleman's bed 100 rubles I don't know
what conversion you might not enter and
I'm not saying that because you're a
Russian Harwich I don't think you were
Russians by I think there are plenty of
dumb Amer I don't mean you're dumb
either but I think there are plenty of
Americans who who support Donald Trump
and they think they're doing the right
thing okay but a lot of I see oh come on
you're telling me that you think Donald
Trump will be there until January 19
2025
yes yeah and here's why gentlemen's bet
he's out by Christmas
I mean tell me I asked the creditor it
looks like he's trying to get impeached
it looks like he's admitted obstruction
of justice at least twice you don't see
it that we might here's what I see what
I see is that there's absolutely
coordinated attack against the president
look at this just since he left since
he's been in the air
they've been four five stories all an
anonymous sourcing that tries to be
detrimental to the president why what's
the point he's going on this well great
trip
first time a president has gone to the
great three religions to the homes of
the three like get back to that got a
glossary she could happy which religion
are you dis carry I'm Jewish okay so
he's going to Israel for the first time
you want Obama one turismo for the first
time 2013 [ __ ] me or him can what an
[ __ ] or not - no I'm telling joking
of course
okay what okay ah well we'll see but but
you okay so since we're not going to
agree on the part that isn't completely
now nailed down by law enforcement let's
just go to the part that's
incontrovertible which is that the
Russians meddled in the election all
seventeen of our intelligence Edgley say
that you would agree to that right well
somehow on and on so that we can get
into the back and forth into my new show
of that letter you're talking about the
absolute letter this all gauges happens
on your agencies have said Russia did so
do you think the president didn't win
the election and that answer my question
first all 17 or whose side are you on
I'm on America side okay but then all of
our intelligence agencies do say this
you don't back so there's a special
counsel and the special counsel will
come out with an answer and I'm
confident it'll show that there was no
just like the president said no
collusion now whether what's up tried to
or not definitely said this is not
collusion question this is the part
that's not controversial this is the
middle question meddling Russia metals
in our election please have to do have
to ask Russia with really tall for
[ __ ] sake
okay with in your ear ear of the like
ear like your boy Trump you're saying
you don't believe our intelligence
agencies no what I'm saying is this what
you don't the presently answer this is
what they say president won the election
fair and square
that's not a toy or the question whether
there was uncomfortable again how would
I know that's me - because our
intelligence agencies all of them say
there was okay okay well so save ours
what is why we are having a pro book so
so cause I can't even get you to come to
the place that all people including the
Republicans agree is the fact that
Russia did meddle in our election and I
thought agree to stop it as if we're a
Seattle it is settled science okay fine
I'm not near the credits and okay I know
the guy coming up I'm foreshadowing okay
is this gonna do that they'll be funny
but shouldn't there be a price for
meddling you know it's funny Jimmy
Carter was known as the great [ __ ] but
when the Russians took over Afghanistan
in 1980 he boycotted the Olympics he
stops telling them grainy took a lot of
political eat for that that actually
took balls to not go to the Olympics
they're very popular yes I love what's
the price that the Russians have paid
for meddling in our election none he has
them into the White House he says it was
a fantastic meeting for who whose side
are you on I'm again very much in
America side I'm on the president's side
and but here's what I make the same
thing Rex Rex Tillerson restful meant to
Russia that is me recommended families
another idiot who did not even raise the
hacking issue with the Russians again if
you have a problem with how the
president and his foreign policy you
could speak at the ballot box in three
and a half years absolutely that's every
American try so
so now Comey he's going to testify this
came out just a couple hours ago all
right so we have he said he said but
call me says one thing Trump says have
it on the one hand you have the guy who
politifact says is the greatest liar in
history of American politics Donald
Trump and then Boy Scouts Jim Carr well
who do you think the American people are
going to think is lying so two weeks ago
Jim Comey was absolutely unpopular and
completely disgusted not Natalie and now
he's about as popular as Mother Teresa
I mean this is somebody who a couple
weeks ago both the left and the right
couldn't stand now and now Jim not
everybody is gonna beacon lots of people
on the Left were where I was with Jim
Coney like what senator Warner said I
didn't agree with everything he did I
didn't call for his resignation well a
lot of Democrats did a lot of it and
they may wanna take yes okay and I let's
take a step back on that doll for a
second so if you talk about that he says
he said in the notes so what Jim Comey
or his people are letting us to believe
is that she took these notes and then
these notes being leaked are we okay
with people going to the Oval Office
taking notes and then leaking those
notes to the press to me there's a huge
problem man
well but isn't the crime itself worse
than the note taking those look
so so it's Hillier if this was Hillary
let's just put it around because how
that's I know but that's how we can tell
if we're being partisan or whether we're
looking at the facts if if if if Obama
during when they were looking at Hillary
had said you know because Trump said
about to call me about Flynn he's a good
guy I'd love it if you could just let
this go if Obama had called me in when
he was looking at Hillary and said you
know she's a good broad I'd be great if
we could just let this go you'd be cool
with that which had Bill Clinton talking
to Loretta Lynch on her plane about that
mural thing right I'm so good so I'm so
good he wasn't the president someone
said but yeah but cute appeal to her to
Jackson or you know that no I I said it
last week absolutely all right let me
ask you this um cuz I just have to know
why someone like yourself is such a fan
of Donald Trump you have kids I do have
a guy when you're okay did you see him
at the commencement for the coast guard
the other day okay he's talking to the
commitment commensurate to kids
fresh-faced idealistic going out into
the world and he starts bitching and
moaning about I am in history and I say
this with great surety not a great
charity are not not a great impression
not a great word great surety that no
politician has ever been treated worse
in history and Nelson Mandela's ghost
went I was in jail for 27 years
what just tell me just tell me why
someone who I bet is otherwise a decent
human being with children how you can
look at that a guy who never takes
responsibility who is always whining and
bitching and moaning and lying just put
me out of my misery and tell me why you
like this man so let me talk about the
down tub I know he is pragmatic he is
smart I keep time he's supportive and
honestly she is the best politician I've
ever worked with I've been on the last
three Republican presidential campaign
and first what we won which was nice and
second of all he's a great communicator
he's great in relating to people I know
all is disagree I know the audience is I
mean I'm terrified tough gig
but if you there's a reason that he got
206 electoral votes right there's a
reason that this president irizarry
president related the electoral college
now but you know we lost the popular
vote you look me up what if now he
doesn't election if the election were
based on the popular vote we would have
campaigned in California we would
campaign in New York and would have won
going away in California New York yeah
because you know la is not the only part
of California neither San Francisco
there are a lot of other parts right
which support Republic you're not going
to win California you know let me just
save you I'm saying that if it was good
on the popular vote
a lot of people all right you know I bet
there's a please 30 percent voters in
the audience
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for that thing he came here
outside
he came here you gotta give it to him
for that